c'est très simple vous voyez il y à
tapis qui va partir il va falloir aller
buzz et mélanger des boulettes à chaque
fois ils râlent et de plus en plus vite
d'accord les cherry est bien ainsi deux
sur trois arrive à buzz et tout le
public part à la mer de sable
on va démarrer avec maxime kenny
attention ces sentiers dax a gagné sans
me faire plus de 6 pour le tapis jusque
là il va courir de m oh oui ça il va se
prendre à la label avancement mais tu
sais pas partie mais recule argent à
l'état c'est parti vite choisi
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
salam a testé tous
gr les robots isabelle je voulais en
attester toiture pour l'instant seros
avant l'accès à la haute cour à toi
bernard maxime maxime je te donne le
poids
[Applaudissements]
marc toi barre toi merci nana attention
bernard à 17 at war
non
the soul salsa del jeu sol ca net
récurrent l'année prochaine non non non
qu'est ce que vous nous régler est
rajouté de la mousse ailleurs d'après
ils ont été traumatisés mais se jouer au
mental
alé lô tard sur la ligne alors me déçoit
pas beaucoup car attention mokhtar tout
va se jouer sur toi est ce que tu es
prêt c'est très chaud
si sur les chaussons attention rouge
trois dates
[Applaudissements]
m
oui
[Applaudissements]